in a nutshell what are some basic
storytelling principles for a screenplay
you had to have a list of bullet points
I would say for me it it really is the
understanding of the wound that drives
and the negative narrative that gets in
the way and how the pursuit is one step
toward healing the wound I would say
that's definitely one I would say
another story tool that I use is that
also goes into the why
is how does the personal dilemma of the
central character link to the
professional pursuit and really being
clear on if there's a link and very
often there isn't a link you're setting
up a weakness or a void that isn't
connected to the pursuit and how the
pursuit can be the answer to that void
and then I would say having an active
hero who has a clear want is definitely
a huge thing that I work with writers on
because it's really thinking about I
mean I think when I first started
consulting one of the biggest questions
I asked was what is the central
character mod if I don't know that the
story doesn't work like what I came to
recognize when I wrote storyline I
recognized there were a hundred
screenwriting books out there what's
going to make my voice different and at
that point I had been an analyst for 17
years so I recognized that analyzing was
what sets me apart because I know how to
do that that's what my brain has been
trained for and so I got a bunch of
Oscar nominated Emmy nominated and
Golden Globe nominated scripts and I
extracted a formula because I thought I
don't want to teach writers how to write
a good script because that won't get
them staffed and that won't lead them to
sell a script I want to teach them how
to write
if that hits it out of the ballpark and
that formula that I came upon was every
strong story starts with a trigger
incident or inciting incident as many
people tournament that pushes the
central character into a powerful
dilemma then the choice that is made in
the dilemma is what defines the external
goal for the a story and every obstacle
escalating obstacle in all is lost
moment need to link back to that choice
and when the goal isn't clear the story
doesn't work because everything needs to
link back to like there are countless on
features as well as TV shows we're in
the middle of the story you have no idea
what central character wants like you've
lost it
because the actions and obstacles aren't
linked to the desire and we lose a sense
of what the desire was so when you do
that story doesn't work and and very
often all writers will write a passive
hero that isn't taking action another
mistake writers will make is they'll
choose the wrong lead they'll develop
another character more with regards to
backstory and empathy then they will
their lead interesting yeah so they
choose the wrong lead so if someone's
looking at their story how can they tell
they have a passive hero are they taking
action toward the goal it's very easy
are they reacting to what happens to
them
like many if you look at act breaks the
at the act break the central character
should take an action toward the goal
hit an obstacle and there should be a
reminder of the stakes that's if the
stakes were set up well
at the beginning and and the internal
and the external states should be felt
at that act break but many times the act
break is something that happens to the
central character rather than it being a
result of an action they took toward the
goal that led to the obstacle how soon
should the key desire be revealed within
the story that's a good question and of
ak1 we should have a clear sense of what
the central character wants by the end
of Act one then now and I am always
studying story and figuring out how to
teach in a way that will connect with
the writer so I go off of the brilliant
work being produced and I would say that
I've seen the end of act 1 d on the
clear set up of the goal and that works
well or I've seen act one end on the
first action taken toward the goal and
the first obstacle hit so either of
those are fine I would say I'm probably
most stories the first action toward the
goal is often nap too
you